[MUSIC PLAYING]
ELIAS PINTO: Welcome to "Cloud
On Air," the live webinars
from Google Cloud.
We are hosting
webinars every Tuesday.
My name is the Elias Pinto.
I'm a customer
engineer in New York.
And today, we're joined
by Prabhu Palanisamy
from SpringML.
We will be talking about how
to make your media content
discoverable and engaging.
For folks on the line, you
can ask questions any time
on the platform, and we
have Googlers on standby
to answer them.
So, Prabhu, why
don't you tell us
a little bit about yourself,
and what you do at SpringML?
Why don't you take it away?
PRABHU PALANISAMY: All right.
Thanks, Elias.
Hello, everyone.
Thanks for the opportunity
to present SpringML and some
of our mission landing
use cases we recently
implemented for our customers.
By the way of introduction,
my name is Prabhu Palanisamy,
I'm one of the
co-founders at SpringML.
I'm delighted to give
an intro of SpringML
and highlight some of the
Google Cloud technologies
from a machine
learning standpoint.
SpringML we started in 2015 and
specializing in data analytics
and machine learning.
Our two strategy partners
are Google and Salesforce.
We specialize in a couple of
verticals, namely media, health
care, technology, and energy.
Today, we are going to focus
on media and entertainment
industry and showcase some of
the applications in machine
learning.
From a capability
standpoint, SpringML
has deep, deep integration and
data processing experience.
Coupled with machine
learning and advanced data
analytics makes it ideal
for enterprises who
have data intensive use cases.
From a recognition
standpoint, SpringML
is one of very few companies
in the world in the Google
ecosystem that has machine
learning and data analytics
specialization.
Here, I'm going to highlight a
couple of vertical domains that
have what I call data
intensive use cases.
For example, energy has
a lot of exploration.
GP has related use cases,
health care on the payer side,
provider side.
And, of course, media--
the discussion of
the topic today
generate a vast amount of media
files, audio files, and image
files on a daily basis.
Traditionally,
implementing insights
using machine learning
for these large data sets
has been challenging.
With the introduction of
Google machine learning APIs
and some of the
frameworks, makes it easy
for us to implement such
solutions to our enterprise
customers in a matter
of days and not months.
A quick overview of SpringML
and how we serve our customers.
SpringML provides a combination
of applications and services.
Applications are
lightweight frameworks
that have prebuilt
machine learning models
and associated
functionalities built in.
And from a services
standpoint, we
help customers to go through
the implementation cycle
all the way from strategy,
integration, implementation,
and continuing the
virtuous cycle.
So what we believe at SpringML
is a journey, our customers
where we take them on a
journey of implementation
and making them successful
in machine learning and data
analytics.
To just quickly summarize
from a SpringML standpoint,
SpringML is one of the premier
partners in the Google Cloud
ecosystem that has
specialization in data
analytics and machine learning.
Now to come to the
topic of the discussion
today, if you look
at it, digital assets
grow on a daily basis.
These are some of
the steps that I
pulled from Gartner
Research and other agencies.
Data that is generated
today, 90% of those data sets
are now in the form of an image,
audio file, or a video file.
Chief Scientist Fei-Fei
Li at Google aptly
puts it as dark
matter of the web.
These are assets that
are under-analyzed.
Now, with the use of Google
machine learning APIs,
I'm going to go through a
set of use cases and demos
that will highlight
the implementation
of these technologies
and how customers
can take advantage and
build new sources of revenue
using these media assets.
So let's break it down.
What I mean by digital
assets or media asset,
it could be one or more or a
combination of the above here.
It could be an audio file.
It could be a video file.
It could be an image file.
And customers traditionally
look for type of analysis,
for example, a video file.
Customers look to do some
transcription associated
with it, find objects of
interest-- location, a person,
or if there is an audio
attached to the video, what
type of sentiment, or what
the conversation is around.
As you may imagine here,
there are multiple levels
of analysis.
For example, if we take a video
file, how we can break it down
into frames, analyze the
frames, find the insights
from the frames, and in
parallel, do transcription.
Find the text, the language
associated with it,
and even find
objects of interest
or even perform Optical
Character Recognition, or OCR.
For example, if there is a
logo present in the video,
what type of logo
can I recognize then?
Now, walk through
these use cases.
Hopefully, I bugged your
interest to showcase
what type of media files
and how to analyze them.
Let me walk through one by one.
For example, image files--
customers are interested in
finding what type of image
file it is and who is
there in the image.
Can I read that image to
find insights from the asset?
Same thing with video files.
If I have long-running
videos and I
need to find
insights quickly, how
can I process them
and avoid human labor?
The demo that I'm
going to show today
is going to be a
long-running video.
Today, if we were
going to process them,
it requires a lot
of human labor.
With the use of
machine learning APIs
and custom tensor flow
models and the Google Cloud
technologies, these processes
cut down the implementation
and the processing time.
Similarly, on the
audio side, how
do we do text transcription,
language translation
to a variety of languages
that the Speech API supports?
And how it applies
to certain use cases
are useful for auditing,
compliance, and other use cases
that we see for our media
and entertainment customers.
So here, I'm going
to switch my screen
and walk through
a couple of demos.
Here is an application that we
built where users can quickly
upload audio files
or video files
and have the machine
learning APIs quickly perform
transcription and
translation and allow
the users to work on this
in a collaborative manner.
Imagine a news journalist
collected information
in the field and has
a raw set of audio
and needs to be
transcripted before having
the editor engage.
Today, these workflows
are disjointed
and requires a lot of back and
forth between the various team
members.
So here in this system
allows transcription
to a variety of languages
that we support.
And from a user
perspective, we make
it very easy for the user
to select an audio file
and get it processed
automatically.
So in this example, I
just selected a file,
and the system uploaded it
into the Google Storage.
And under the hood, it
calls the Google Speech
API and the natural
language processing
API to start deriving
the results out of it.
So for example here, let
me select an audio file
where we see the transcription
and the results of it.
And let me play for a few
seconds to highlight a feature,
and I'll add some commentary.
SPEAKER 1: Artificial
intelligence
is transforming every industry.
In manufacturing--
PRABHU PALANISAMY:
As you can see here,
the results are provided
and the users can now
use the playback
functionality and follow
through the transcription.
This is, again, useful for
news journalists, editors
to start building
the news stories.
Similarly, if I
have a large content
and I need to go
to select key word,
I can just click on
a specific key word
and allow the playback
to start from there.
SPEAKER 1: Video or images
of packages and extracts text
in real time.
If the text does not con--
PRABHU PALANISAMY:
Say, for example,
now the transcription
is complete.
Now, I want to take advantage
of the Google Drive,
or the collaboration.
So, immediately,
the application has
an integration to Google Drive.
And on just a click of a
button, the Google document
is available with
the transcription.
So now I can quickly share,
include other members
for collaboration, comments,
feedback, et cetera.
As I just mentioned,
the same application
supports other languages.
Here is a quick audio feed that
processed to another language.
In this case, it's Hindi.
If we look at the application
of these type of use cases,
one in the past, the accuracy
level of transcription
and translation has
been not up to the level
for an enterprise-grade
deployment.
Today, with the machine learning
APIs that Google deployed--
for example, the
speech to text--
the accuracy level
is so high, people
are looking to deploy it for
enterprise-grade applications.
These type of use cases are
useful for media agencies--
anyone who is generating
content on a daily basis.
Let me switch to
another demo that
highlights the use of
Video Intelligence API
and some of the custom
tensor flow models.
In this demo, I'm
going to showcase
how to process
long-running videos
and extract insights out of it.
This is a video that is around
three hours between Roger
Federer and Stan Wawrinka.
And the challenge here is--
can we use machine learning
to generate a highlight
and helps the editors to avoid
looking at long-running videos?
If you look at a
tennis game, there
are certain things
or points in time
that are useful for editors.
For example, when the referee
says match point or set point,
the system knows that, OK,
that's the crucial point
or event in the game.
Similarly, if there is
a huge audience uproar,
that also means that
that's a crucial game
point between the players.
Also from an editor's
standpoint, is it a long rally,
or is it an ace?
That will also be helpful
from an editor's standpoint.
Now if we look at it, if we
process this three-hour video
and provide these
interesting frames,
now the job of the
editor makes it easier
to look for these
frames and quickly start
putting highlights together.
Let me play a
couple of snapshots
and I'll add my commentary.
For example, here, I'm
going to click a link that
highlights the audience uproar.
SPEAKER 2: Roger Federer is
through to his sixth Australia
Open.
Wawrinka--
PRABHU PALANISAMY:
So if you look here,
these are moments in frames the
editor now has quick editorial
features to start
looking at these frames
and maybe generate
a highlight out of.
Similarly, as I mentioned,
when the referee says a break
point or a match point, it's
also crucial for an editor
to look for.
SPEAKER 2: Arrived, match point.
Two more break points.
PRABHU PALANISAMY:
What we have also done
is we have listed the key frames
for the users to understand,
what is there in this
long running media?
For example here, I want
to see the frame that
has ball on the line.
SPEAKER 2: That's a line-licker.
SPEAKER 3: Game, [INAUDIBLE].
PRABHU PALANISAMY: I
want to see whether it is
a long rally or a short rally.
I want to see if it
is short rally here.
So, for example, if
I select a frame,
this seems to be
[INAUDIBLE] standpoint.
So if we look at it, the basis
is, first, supervised learning.
We sit with the
subject matter textbook
and identify what frames
are useful to capture.
And we apply machine
learning and make
these insights
available for our users
in a quick-to-consume fashion.
If we look at it,
the same concept
can be applied for
any type of videos
from a content standpoint.
What are all the frames
that are of interest to me,
and how can I play apply machine
learning to automatically look
for those frames?
Hopefully this is useful.
Gives an overview of
what we do intelligence.
Let me switch to another
demo that highlights
face recognition and detection.
Here is a demo, where
we apply in addition
to Video Intelligence
API, and also Vision API.
Find in the frame, if
there is a face present.
And if it is a frame
that I can recognize,
find some summary from,
in this case, wiki page.
Let me quickly walk
through the pipeline
and highlight, or
showcase, the demo
and I'll play the video file.
So here is the pipeline that
looks from a demo standpoint.
So we have raw video file.
We process that using the
Video Intelligence API.
The Video Intelligence
API provides coordinates
and face-related
coordinates, again,
from each frame
standpoint-- meaning,
if there is a face present--
and coordinates and the
frame details of the effort.
Then what we do is we
pass it to the Vision API
and find if it is a face
that we can recognize.
And if we are able to
recognize the face,
can I get some summary
details from Wikipedia?
So from a pipeline standpoint,
multiple APIs are involved,
and the data pipeline makes the
integration here much easier,
because all we are doing here
is a couple of API integrations.
So let me play the
video for a few seconds,
and I'll add some commentary.
SPEAKER 4: The
Tyrell Corporation.
SPEAKER 5: Mr Decker,
Dr. Elden Tyrell.
SPEAKER 6: I don't
get it, Tyrell.
SPEAKER 7: Commerce is
our goal here at Tyrell.
More human than
human is our motto.
PRABHU PALANISAMY: So you can
see here, as the video plays,
we are able to use
the functionality
of the intelligence
the API, split
the video into multiple frames.
And within the frame,
we are looking for faces
that the system can recognize.
And as you can see here, the
moment a face is recognized,
we are able to take
a snapshot out of it,
pass it through the Vision API.
And if it is a celebrity,
we can find the details
from the results that are
provided from the Vision API.
And we are able to make
a call to Wikipedia API
to summarize the results.
So now, again, for
functionalities
for customers who
are looking for face
detection and other
location-based intelligence,
these types of use
cases are much easier
to implement with the Google
Cloud framework as well
as the APIs.
Lastly, I'm going to
highlight demo of Vision API
and how to do
document processing.
So if we look at
it, there are a lot
of documents that
are structure space.
Like, it could be
an invoice document,
it could be a purchase order.
There are a lot of
structural documents
that require human
as well as other
workflow-based integrations
to either insert it
into a back end system
for processing, et cetera.
What if we can use
Google Vision API
and see if we can
automate such processes?
For example, in
this demo here, let
me showcase how an
invoice can automatically
extract the key fields
using the Vision API
and, say, integrated
to a Salesforce system.
This will be useful for users
and avoid hand typing or use
of other OCR technologies
from an external integration
standpoint.
So if you look here--
let me start with the
template structure document.
So in this case, it's
a structured template
and can be used
Vision API to extract
some of the key fields-- in this
case name, address, and date,
et cetera.
From a processing
standpoint, what happens
here is this
particular document is
being processed through Vision
API, and we look for entities.
Like say, is there
a named present?
Is there a date present?
And with the combination of
rules based, coordinates based,
and entities based, we can
extract key fields easy.
The same concept if I apply
it to an invoice document.
It's a structured document.
It has certain key fields
that I need to look for, say,
for example, invoice date,
account number, invoice amount,
description, et cetera.
We follow the same
pipeline process,
where we can pass it
to the Vision API.
And now the Vision
API can quickly
give me the results of it.
Now that if I'm able to
extract these entities,
I can integrate to
my back end system.
For example, send this to
a Salesforce application.
Hopefully, that gives
you the overview
of how to process image files,
video files, and applying
Vision for OCR-type use cases.
Let me switch back
to my slide and cover
a couple of lessons
learned, best practices
of some of the
considerations based
on our recent implementations.
As you can see on
the top, if we were
to look at machine learning
for unstructured data sets,
there are a variety
of use cases here.
We can apply APIs.
We can apply new
functionality that Google
released called AutoML, useful
for custom training models.
Similarly, there are
ML kits now available,
makes that mobile application
development much easier.
Then the super
developer-centric tensor
flow with a large
community following,
where we can build and deploy
custom machine learning models.
In addition to it, there are
also other open source tools,
and community has built a lot
of machine learning libraries
for use and integration.
So if we look at it, there are
a lot of options available.
There are API, there are
models, there are open source
frameworks, et cetera.
Some of the considerations
we have seen
is one, defining the user
stories, or requirements.
This is no different from
any of the other project
development or implementation.
Care should be
taken to make sure
that who the user is,
what type of profile,
what's the business value from
an implementation standpoint,
and some of the other
infrastructure-related use
cases.
For example,
authentication, security,
performance, how the error
handling should be applied,
et cetera.
This is where
SpringML can provide
the right guidance and
the implementation support
for all the enterprises.
Similarly, if we
look at it, data
is the core element in deploying
machine learning projects.
So particularly in this
case for media research,
data files are large.
So how do we come up
with a data pipeline
from an integration standpoint?
Where do we store the data?
How do we store the data?
What type of structure that will
help from an analysis of these
files?
Then, finally, the integration.
So, for example, if
I have a media file,
I analyze the media file,
the machine learning works,
now what?
How does this particular
machine learning insight
get integrated to the
existing business uses?
Integration needs to
be thought through
to make sure that the insights
that are derived are useful
and customers can make
informed decisions
based on these insights.
And, finally, migration--
how am I going
to process historical data?
How am I going to make
sure that the past insights
and the new machine
learning model can coexist?
The last piece is once
I have the user stories,
we find the business
alignment is the--
when I have my data
side, the technology team
is in alignment, how the
automation piece of it?
At SpringML, we joke that
machine learning development
is easy, but automation
is super hard.
So how are we going to deploy
these machine learning models,
automate them, and
make the DevOps easier?
Again, Google has come up with
some of the framework that
makes it easy.
For example, for tensor
flow model development,
there is a framework
called cube flow, which
uses the Kubernetes
container model to make
DevOps much easier.
So from an implementation
standpoint,
we need to make sure that
the user stories are defined,
the data side discovered, and
then the automation side of it.
Hopefully that gives
an insight into some
of the lessons learned.
Now, stay tuned for Live Q&A.
We'll be back in less than a
minute.
ELIAS PINTO: And we're back.
Well thank you, Prabhu, for that
presentation and demonstration.
So during the
demonstration, we had
some folks submit some
questions from the audience.
So we wanted to present
some questions to you.
And the first one here--
how long does it
take to implement
one of these projects?
Is there an average duration?
What can you tell us about that?
PRABHU PALANISAMY: Sure, that's
a very good question, Elias,
where we get that from
our customers often.
There is a lot of interest
on machine learning.
There is obviously a lot of
hype associated with it as well.
But when it comes
to implementation,
historically, given
the complexity
and the implementation
duration, customers
fear that it may be
intensive from a resource
standpoint with very minimal
results from the product.
So what we take
through our customers
is taking these projects
in sprint-based, agile,
incremental delivery model.
We want to make
sure we understand
the vision of the customer.
We want to make sure we
understand the long-term goal
and how the customer wants
to derive insights out of it.
Then we break it down
into smaller pieces.
For example, one of the things
at SpringML is if we cannot
show value of a machine
learning project in six weeks,
then we are not defining
the [? version ?] properly.
So the demos and the
projects that I showed
during the session have--
most of those projects
were completed
in six to eight weeks.
That doesn't mean that
we're simplifying it.
But at the same
time, these projects
doesn't have to be implemented
in a traditional multi-month
implementation.
So we make sure we
understand the vision
and come up with an
implementation plan that
comprises of multiple
sprints, and shows
value in each and every
sprint schedule, et cetera, so
that way customers
can take that insight,
adapt it to the
business process,
let the feedback loop come in--
meaning, what are the
business users saying?
Are they finding value in it?
What are the
suggestions that they
are providing from the changes
to the machine learning model?
So we make sure that the
feedback loop comes back
again to the next
sprint schedule and make
sure the machine
learning models that we
built are to the customer
requirements and expectations.
ELIAS PINTO: Thank you.
Thank you.
We have a couple more.
So an audience member said,
I'm already in another cloud,
can I still use machine
learning on Google Cloud?
PRABHU PALANISAMY: Perfect.
This is, again,
a great question.
Customers, particularly
large enterprises,
have a variety of
deployment methods.
And if you look at the
Google Cloud machine learning
tool sets, as I highlighted,
some of the tool sets
are API-based that can be
moved from multiple systems.
Some of the technologies
are open source,
for example TensorFlow.
And from a machine learning
implementation standpoint,
depending on the assets, there
are also hardware dependency
to it.
For example, Google has
a TPU-based framework
to process large data sets,
image files, et cetera.
Google Cloud also
has GPUs to process
data-intensive industries.
And if we look at it, that's
the foundation of Kubernetes
to a certain extent.
So there you have containers,
and you build your application,
deploy it in Kubernetes,
and depending
on the platform or
the cloud of choice,
customer always has options.
So from our
implementation standpoint,
we make sure the customer gets
the advantages of the Google
Cloud machine learning
APIs and leave the option
to the infrastructure team to
the deployment aspect of it.
ELIAS PINTO: Got it.
OK.
Couple more.
So what type of
resources/training
do I need on my team?
Sounds like somebody
is wondering
if they have to go get a PhD.
So what kind of
resources/training
do I need on my team to
do the machine learning?
PRABHU PALANISAMY: Perfect.
So from a project
implementation standpoint,
this is, again, people
fear that I need a PhD
or I need a data scientist, or I
need some exceptional resources
that are far and
few as cost to find.
If you look at it from a machine
learning project, or data
analytics standpoint, the need
for machine learning expertise
is probably 10% to 15% of
the whole project itself.
So that's the core piece--
a core resource needed, but
it is from the larger context
standpoint, it's a small
slice in the implementation.
If we look at it
in our projects,
the data integration tend
to be much longer and much
labor intensive than actual
machine learning development
itself.
And as folks know, the
exercise of data cleaning,
data wrangling, data
processing oftentimes
is much more than
actually machine
learning development itself.
So from a resource
standpoint, some
of the project-related
governance have to be there.
So you need a strong project
manager, a business analyst,
a subject matter expertise
that the customer
knows what is that insight.
And from an implementation
technology standpoint,
obviously a data scientist
and a data engineer
are common resources.
And, particularly, Google
Cloud has done a phenomenal job
on the technology
information backcasting.
For example, I'm a big fan
of Cloud OnAir myself, where
I have learned about
Kubernetes, [? MLKs, ?]
the new technologies
that are being deployed
from Google's standpoint.
So from the feedback
prospective,
resources-wise, I would consider
looking from a holistic project
standpoint.
So as much as you need the
data scientists and the data
engineer, you also need to
have a project manager who
understands what went through
from a machine learning
standpoint.
And also a subject matter
expert, business analysts,
who can communicate the business
users to the data scientists
and engineers.
ELIAS PINTO: Good, I
thought I had to get a PhD.
Good.
PRABHU PALANISAMY: [LAUGHS]
ELIAS PINTO: Thank you.
We have a last--
seems like to be
the last question.
So how do you scale the
processes end to end?
PRABHU PALANISAMY: Yes this
is, again, one of the areas
where a probably project team
or the implementation team
does not see it through the end.
Like I mentioned, oftentimes
machine learning development
is easy, but the
operationalizing part of it
is super hard.
So from the
processes standpoint,
how do you scale end to end?
So the infrastructure side of
it needs to be thought through.
And also from the business
side of it, as I said,
that feedback loop
is very important.
Am I seeing value?
Am I deriving the
value out of it?
And, accordingly, make the
production deployment elastic.
Today, with the
introduction of containers,
I don't need to have a scale
of processing 100 nodes all
the time.
You come up with a
model, you deploy it.
If the business users like it,
if the customers are liking it,
they are deriving the value,
scale on a need basis.
And with the
Kubernetes cube flow
and some of the
container-based implementation,
it makes it easier.
So you can start small.
For example, some of the
projects that I showcased often
has large data sets.
For example, a
three-hour tennis video
quickly run into [INAUDIBLE],,
similarly, other media
companies.
So if we were a set up on
infrastructure on the get-go,
it may look monumental.
Rather, we can start small,
scale, and use the Google Cloud
functionalities.
Most of the Google
Cloud product suites--
for example, App
Engine, Kubernetes--
allow to do elastic scaling.
Make sure that
infrastructure team
is aware of it and
the configuration set
in a way you can start small,
scale based on feedback.
And, obviously, with Google
Cloud, some of the resources
are infinite scale.
ELIAS PINTO: So we built
a data center already.
You don't need to
build another one.
PRABHU PALANISAMY: Excellent.
ELIAS PINTO: Excellent.
I think that's all the
questions that we have today.
So for the folks online,
please stay tuned.
We have another
session coming up,
and it's titled "99
Problems but GPU Ain't One."
Sounds like a fun one.
So, again, my name is
Elias and Prabhu here.
And we thank you for your
participation with questions.
And until next time.
[MUSIC PLAYING]